So, welcome back. So, if you are having any questions please you know keep them. So, we
are already noting down. So, towards the end we will have a long question answering session.
So, at that time we will discuss. Let us go back to composition of transformation. So,
the discussion that we had was that basically how you can design the architecture of neural
network ok. For you to understand this you have to understand how a neural network operate
ok. So, you see this is where sort of the term learning representation or representation
learning comes into picture. So, this is another term you would have heard which is called
representation learning right. So, what happens is each neuron in the neural network can be
thought of as computing a useful I so, representation slash here I would use more the word feature
ok representation or features of the input ok. In particular every layer is computing
a useful representation of the input. So, if let us let us go into one example to make
it very clear ok. So, you see these green data points are some data points in a x y space
ok and blue data points are some other data points ok. Now, you see you can do this kind
of a feature transformation. What is the feature transformation that we are doing? We are computing
for every data point from its x and y value this particular two numbers. First is R what
is R as you all know from your geometry knowledge R is nothing, but the radial distance of this
particular point from the origin right this distance is R ok.
So, this is the first thing that you compute and the other thing that you compute is this
theta ok which is let me try to do it like this. So, for example, for this point this
is going to be theta right this is going to be the theta and this you already know from
your geometry. Now, consider this particular feature space where you are so, so R you can
say is one useful feature it is the radius it is one useful feature of this particular
data point theta is another useful feature which is the angle of this data point ok.
Now you you now construct another space ok this space you represent each data point x
axis value using R and its y axis value using theta ok. So, how will this particular distribution
of points look like it will look like this because you see x axis is R. So, now now this
particular distance is R right this particular distance is R ok. So, for the green point
R will be much smaller than the blue point here and y axis value is theta ok y axis value
is theta. So, each point has some theta ok ok. So, now now two three things you should
observe first is you can have simply this R as a representation for a particular point
ok. It is a useful feature in this particular problem see you your task is to segregate
the green point from the blue point ok this red line here is the separator line ok. So,
so this this red line is able to separate. So, if you just have a particular radial distance
you are able to separate the green point from the blue point. So, R is a useful feature,
but R is not a complete representation of the point, but it is a useful representation
ok. When you take R and theta together they form a complete representation of the point
because you can compute the x y back from R and theta ok.
But for the purpose of this task for the purpose of segregating blue and green only the R is
sufficient you can understand that right even if you do not have theta. So, if I have one
neuron which is computing the R and then there is another neuron which is able to put a threshold
on this R ok. Then that is good enough for this particular computation ok. So, this is
the key idea. So, here R is a useful representation ok. So, let me just erase this. So, this is
a useful representation ok may not be complete you can also have a complete representation
which is given by R from a theta ok. The representation is useful because the end task becomes much
simpler in this R theta space ok than it was in the original space ok. So, this is how
the neural networks operate. Every layer of a neural network computes a useful representation
of the input feature ok and then it the next layer uses this particular useful representation
of the input feature to further compute some other useful feature ok.
This is one thing there is another term that you will hear a lot in this context is that
these are distributed representation. So, what does it mean by saying that these are
distributed representation? The key idea here is that you see for each data point you can
compute its useful feature which is R independently of all other data points and you can also
do this in parallel ok. So, that is why this is called a distributed representation which
means that the representation of one particular data point does not depend on the representation
of the other data points. It only depends on the particular neural network weight or weights
of that particular layer ok. So, this is the idea behind the distributed representation
and neural networks operate by learning layers of increasingly useful distributed representation
ok. So, representations are formed hierarchically in each layer progressively becoming more
useful for the end task ok. That is why neural networks are also called feature encoders
ok. Now, here notice another thing up till now whatever representation I have showed
either this R or this other representation that we showed here using this H 1 and H
2 ok. Both these representations I have constructed manually ok, but now in neural networks what
happens is you need not construct the representation manually you can learn the representation ok.
So, that is why you sometimes will see that this neural network models are also called
automatic feature learning model or representation learning model ok ok. So, here is another example
to drive home the point that basically what you can think is you can think of a neural
network as a composition of the feature transformation. So, what is happening here? So, let us say
you have for a particular patient the age, gender and the stage of their cancer ok and
let us say what you want to compute is the probability of being alive survivability
or something like that ok. So, what you can see is basically that there
are let us say two types of feature encoders. So, this is the whole neural network ok. So,
the first part the top left part is this particular hidden representation what it is doing? It
is giving high weightage to age and high weightage to the stage of cancer and it is predicting
something ok. The second one is giving more weightage to gender and maybe age and stage
of cancer. So, you can say that roughly the first neuron is capturing information which
is the interaction between age and stage of cancer. So, maybe if the age is high and the
stage is also high the probability of being alive is low or something like that ok. So,
this is one way to think about it. On the other hand the there is also a gender
component. So, maybe one gender has a higher probability of surviving cancer than the second
gender. So, in that case this particular neuron is capturing that particular feature ok.
And now the final layer is basically taking the output of these two neuron and trying
to construct a final layer which is a linear layer which is a basically sort of a linear
model. It is not exactly a linear model it is a linear separator, but the model is non-linear
of the you know the final output ok. So, this is this is the composition of transformation
view. So, this is you can think of this as this is one particular transformation, this
is the second transformation and then this is the composition of transformation and
transformation two ok. Now, what you can see is that. So, there is one result which says
that a neural network with simply one hidden layer is a uniform function approximator.
What does this mean? You take any function F there are certain conditions. So, the function
has to be smooth function ok, its derivative has to be bounded etcetera ok. If that is
the case then this particular function. So, the function will take different values for
different input point A and let us say you have learned a one layer one two layer neural
network basically a neural network with one hidden layer ok. Let us call that F dashed
of A ok. So, the difference between these two or the distance. So, this is the norm
function right. So, the distance between these two for different x values will be less than
or equal to some epsilon for all x ok. So, this is what it means ok. So, for all input
x the difference between the output of the neural network and the actual function F will
be very low for all x ok. So, it is possible to construct for every F that kind every F
satisfying certain properties that kind of a neural network ok.
Now this is a very shallow neural network ok. So, if you construct a neural network with
only one hidden layer this will be called a shallow neural network ok. And you can very
easily learn using existing algorithm you can very easily learn this kind of a neural
network. The problem is that not all functions can be efficiently represented with a single
hidden layer. So, what do we mean by this? We mean to say that there are certain functions
for which if you have to construct which can be approximated by a neural network of this
form. Let us say this is the neural network ok. So, this is basically computing F of x
this is just x ok. So, you can compute this F dash of x can compute F of x for a function.
But the number of the number of let us say hidden unit that you will require here will
be exponentially large or will be very large ok. So, it is a good. So, which means what
does that mean? That means that since every layer is every neuron is connected to every
neuron you will need to have weights here and you will need to have weights here. So, the
number of weights will also be very very large ok. And as you know if the number of so weights
are parameters of the neural network, if the number of weights is very very large the
number of data points and the amount of computation that is needed to train this neural network
will also be very very large ok. So, this is the problem with shallow neural network ok.
The solution is to have deeper representation with which is the composition that we talked
about that you build representations in one layer then you compose those representations
to build representation in another layer ok. Let me just show with an example what I mean
ok. So, suppose you have the input as an image ok. If you directly try to build let
us say a face recognition or a face detector event neural network let us say ok. You it
may not be you may need it may be possible ok with just one hidden layer, but the number
of neurons. So, here you can see that each pixel is an input and also like in. So, this
is the layer 1 the first hidden layer. So, this is layer 1 ok the first hidden layer.
Here also each pixel corresponds to one output maybe there are certain number of channels
which are being showed here we will come to that when we discuss convolutional neural
network, but essentially you are saying that the number of outputs is roughly of the same
order as the number of inputs ok, but if you try to achieve this face detection in one layer
maybe it is possible to achieve that, but the number of output neurons that you will
need in this layer will be very very large ok. But here you see it is possible to achieve
edge detection using one layer of transformation. So, using one neuron you can achieve this
edge detection here ok. Then taking the edge detector output as the input in one layer
you can maybe say object path detector maybe corner detector or something like a like a
circle detector or small polygon edge detector something like that ok. This kind of things
you can construct ok and then maybe you can compose those to finally construct a face
detector which is maybe a composition of some polygon some circle some triangle and so on
and so forth ok. So, this is the this is what I mean by saying
that there is merit in having a deep neural network even though you know theoretically
it may be possible to achieve this using a single layer ok.
Now, yeah so then some people ask so the people ask the question what is like when do we call
a neural network deep. So, like I said deep learning is nothing but learning with neural
network ok, but it is learning with deep neural network. So, then the question is how deep
is deep ok and so I am just giving a ballpark number here. So, this is not set in stone
or anything ok, but maybe three four layer is not so deep ok. So, if you use three or
maybe even four layers then it is a shallow neural network after that it becomes a deep
neural network. Now, then the question is why do we need to make this segregation between
a deep neural network and shallow neural network ok and the reason is these kind of practical
problems that you encounter when you try to train a deep neural network, but these problems
are not so much encountered when you try to train a shallow neural network.
So, what is the what is the problem? First problem is so all neural networks you need
to use back propagation algorithm that is not a that is common between deep and shallow
neural network. For designing deep neural network you need a modular approach. So, what
I just showed here? So, maybe you have to have an idea of what kind of representation
you are trying to achieve in each layer. So, like first layer is A j, second layer is object
part maybe not each layer, but you know for many layers you need to have an idea of what
kind of representation you are trying to achieve. This is the first thing.
The second more important problem is that of vanishing gradients. So, as the number
of layers increase what happens is when you try to back propagate the error to learn the
way we will see the exact method in a minute. The gradient starts becoming very very low.
What happens is that that causes training to be very very slow or sometimes it just stops
training. So, that is the other problem that you need specialized training method for deep
neural network in order to tackle the vanishing gradient problem which you do not need for
the shallow neural network. So, these are the main reasons why this deep neural network
is basically thought of as from a practical point of view as somewhat different than the
shallow neural network. And yeah, so this is like the key point which is that it has
been shown again and again in multiple different applications that this hierarchical buildup
of useful features in a deep manner is much more helpful than if you try to fit a shallow
neural network. So, we will come to this training of deep neural networks in a minute.
Now let us discuss how we train a neural network. So, how do we train a neural network? So,
this is the neural network. So, broadly these are the steps. What are the steps? You randomly
initialize. So, when you have a neural network, so first at this point in time you know what
is the architecture of the neural network which means you know how many layers are there,
you know how many neurons are there in each layer and mostly in this particular lecture
we are talking about fully connected layer. Of course, you can also not have fully connected
layers, it will still work. But for simplicity of understanding today let us discuss only
fully connected layers. So, that means you also know which neuron is connected to which
neuron. So, everything is fixed now. So, if the architecture of the neural network
is fixed as you know the weight matrices which is W kj and W ji in this particular case these
are also fixed as I as we discussed earlier. So, what you do is you initialize these weight
matrices with random value at the time of training. Then using this random weight you
feed the input x. So, first of all you have a training dataset D. What is this training
dataset going to be like? So, this training dataset is going to be like x i comma y i
right input is x i, your input is x i and your output is y i and now you have i is equal
to 1 to capital N. So, you have capital N many training data points which we discussed in
the beginning. So, maybe you have 1 million training data points it is very common to
have 1 million training data points today. So, for each input now you feed the input
into the neural network and then you do the forward propagation calculation. The forward
propagation calculation we have already seen how to do. So, first you come from layer 1
you compute layer 2 from that you compute layer 3 and so on and so forth. So, this is
the forward propagation calculation and then finally, you compute the predicted output
ok. After you compute the predicted output let us call the predicted output something
like y i hat and you have the true output also in the training data which is y i. So,
now you compute you compare the predicted output with true output and you compute the
error. So, depending on what the output is a different errors can be computed and then
so, these errors are sometimes also called loss. So, there is a loss function which basically
depends on of course, the parameters of the neural network let us call the parameter something
like theta. So, theta here just for simplicity is w k j matrix and w j i matrix right the
two matrices ok. And now this theta and also it depends on the input x i and the true level
y i ok. And another way of thinking about it is suppose your neural network is f. So,
your neural network is of course, parameterized by theta ok. So, suppose your neural network
is outputting y hat i which is is equal to f of x i then you can also say this is a loss
between f theta of x i which is y hat and y i ok. So, you compare this y hat which is
f theta of x i with y i ok. So, this is how you compute the loss. Now you compute the
total loss which is summation over i is equal to 1 to capital N l of x i and y i let us
say and also theta of course ok. And then you minimize this total loss by adjusting the
parameter. So, what you do you adjust the parameter theta such that this total loss
is minimized. So, you minimize this total loss with respect to theta. So, that is the
training problem of neural network ok. So, that is the overall scheme. Now how is this
achieved? Of course, you have a neural network like this. So, algorithmically you put in
the training inputs get the output ok. So, then you compare the output to the correct
answers to look at the loss function j. So, this is this is. So, we are calling the loss
function j here ok. We are calling the loss function j ok and then we adjust the weights
and repeat ok. So, let us let us see how this goes on ok.
Now before we do this this procedure is called a gradient descent procedure ok. So, now what
is this gradient descent procedure? Let us see ok. So, the first step is clear I am going
to quickly go over this pass input calculate each layer get output which is y hat. Evaluate
j of y i y hat which is the loss function ok. So, these steps are pretty clear. Now the
this step is calculate gradient of the loss function with respect to the parameter ok.
So, what is the loss function? So, let me see. So, what is the loss function? So, remember
we can think of neural network as this function approximator which is f from x to y. So, neural
network is a mapping from x to y ok. f is a complex computation involving many weights
w ok. For a given structure the weights define the function ok. So, like I said f of theta
x is equal to y hat right. Now when we say j of f of x basically this j becomes a function
of theta because you see both x and y are known ok. Only thing that is not known is
theta which we have to minimize with respect to x ok. So, how do we do this gradient descent?
We do the following ok. We compute the partial derivative of this function j ok. So, j here
is the total loss function. Remember j is earlier we were writing as f of xi comma yi,
but also actually your j of theta is summation over i is equal to 1 to capital N this thing
ok. So, it is this total loss. So, this particular j is the total loss over all xi's and yi's
ok. xi's and yi's are data point ok. So, it is the total loss over all xi's and yi's.
Of course, theta's consist of all the w's. So, may be w k j etcetera etcetera. So, there
are many w's ok. Now you compute this partial derivative of j with respect to every w k
ok, every parameter k ok. So, how many partial derivatives are going to be there? As many
as there are parameters ok. So, as many as there are parameters or weights in the neural
network you are going to compute that many partial derivative ok. So, if we and this
is going to be a very complex structure ok. So, there may be multiple layers, each layer
may have a different size weight matrix ok. So, all these need to be kept track of by
the software which is implementing this back propagation algorithm ok, but suppose you
are able to compute this particular gradient which is this del of j comma w k ok ok. So,
I will come to the backward pass in a minute, but suppose you are able to do that what happens
to the updation step. So, you do this particular update which is the gradient descent update
which is that every parameter. So, here you see the parameter is being denoted by w ok.
The w t is basically the parameter in time step t and w t plus 1 is the parameter in
time step t plus 1 ok. So, initially you random. So, initially what you have? You have w 0
ok. w 0 you have initialized randomly ok. From w 0 you compute w 1 through this particular
equation. What is the equation? The equation is the gradient descent step which is that
w t plus 1 is w t minus eta t times this partial derivative with respect of the loss with respect
to that parameter w that we have computed ok. So, this is the step. This step we will
run iteratively until these w's are no longer changing which also happens when this particular
gradient becomes 0 ok. These are these are well known results from optimization theory
we I am not going to discuss it here ok, but this is the case ok. So, sounds good. So,
if you have the partial derivative which is also called the gradient with respect to each
parameter then you can do this step ok. Question is how do you your neural network is a complex
function? So, here is a complex neural network structure right. So, this particular so in
the final layer you are computing this yeah. So, this j you are computing here in the final
layer right. So, the question is how do you compute this particular gradient for each
w k ok that is the question ok and the answer is that just like you did layer by layer forward
propagation you have to do a layer by layer backward propagation ok.
So, first here you have this j of y i comma y i hat ok. From that you compute the derivative
of j with respect to the third layer parameter. So, here w t 3 is denoting all the third
layer parameters ok. Once you have these gradients then you can compute the gradients of the
second layer parameter ok and then you can compute the gradient of the first layer parameter
ok. This is how you do the backward path computation. So, this is the formula for the whole thing
ok. Let me first try to derive the formula in a simpler network ok and then we will see
how this goes ok. So, consider this very very simple. So, I have changed the notation just
so that the calculation because this is a complex calculation. So, that the calculation
is very simple. So, what is the calculation? You have x as the input. So, this is x ok
x is the input. It is a two layer neural network first layer produces this output z ok. Not
the first layer does not produce the output. This is the intermediate activation you can
say ok. So, this z is the input to the activation function f is the activation function and
a is the output of the activation function. So, this layer produces output a. This layer
is x, x goes through this produces z, z goes through the activation function produces a.
Then the final layer is s which is again a linear function of the output produced by
this a ok. So, this is the neural network architecture that we want to see and what
is our ask? Our ask is that we want to compute the derivative of s with respect to both u
and w. So, our parameters are u and w and we want to compute derivative of s with respect
to u ok. So, first derivative of s with respect to u is very simple to compute. What is it
going to be? It is simply going to be it is simply going to be this a whatever is the
activation output here. So, if you have in this layer if you have this a 1 and a 2. So,
what is so let us say your s is going to be nothing but u i u 1 a 1 plus u 2 a 2 right
here ok. So, what is the derivative of s with respect to let us say u 1 it is simply going
to be a 1 ok. So, that is simple to compute because that is the output layer that is the
final layer ok. Now, what is the derivative of s with respect
to let us say this w i j this is what we want to compute ok. How do we compute this? So,
we compute derivative of s, s is u transpose a ok. Now, what is the derivative of a with
respect to w i j? So, u does not depend on w i j ok. So, this simply become derivative
of a with respect to w i j ok. So, what is the derivative of a with respect to w i j?
Again a if you remember a depends on z right a is f of z. So, you further use the chain
rule to say derivative of a i with respect to z i and then derivative of z i with respect
to w i j. Now, what is this term? This term is f dashed of z i and what is this term?
This term is z i with respect to w i j this is nothing, but if you see ok z i with respect
to w i j is simply x i right ok. So, sorry z i with respect to w i j. So, it is going
to be x j yeah. So, derivative of this is z i with respect to w i j is going to be x
j ok ok. So, what do we have here? We have u i times f dashed z i times x j ok. This
is the derivative of w i j which is this particular parameter let us say with respect
to the previous layer error ok. Now, if we see what was the derivative of let us see.
So, yeah ok. So, what was ok? So, you can see that there are few signals that you need
to take into account ok. So, what is the first signal? First signal is this upstream error.
What is the upstream error? This is u i times f dashed z i ok. This is the upstream error
signal ok. This is as I have written here the gradient of the error with respect to
the activation in the current nodes ok. So, sometimes this is further split into the upstream
error. So, as you are coming back in the neural network this can also split into more and
more error signals ok. And the other thing is this downstream input which is in this
particular case x j ok. So, just to be clear this is the layer where
you are computing the error. This is the layer where so, let me just erase this. So, this
is the layer because the w i j's are part of this layer right. So, this is the layer
where you are computing the error. You are getting this if you remember is input from
here error signal from upstairs and the derivative of the activation function. So, f dashed x
times u i times this x this was the computation right if you remember here ok. So, this is
the x j this is w i j ok and this is a i ok. So, your derivative let me say once more derivative
of f with respect to w i j this is w i j this is x j this is a i ok. This is going to be
equal to we have done this derivation already and this is u i of course this is u i ok.
This is going to be u i time f dashed z i time x j ok. So, this is the derivative and
you can see you need the error signal the signal here is basically the error signal
that is coming from top ok. So, that is why you need to calculate from top down ok. So,
this is the back propagation algorithm ok. Now, so up till now this is clear ok. So,
you now know. So, this is basically for this deep neural network your formulas should come
out to be something like this you should do the calculation by hand because this calculation
will take more time you do the calculation by hand and check that this is actually the
case ok. Now, let me come to this particular thing ok now what is the difference between
training deep neural networks and shallow neural networks ok? So, in as I said now you
can understand that you are multiplying many many upstream error signals into computing
the derivative in this layer. So, let us say it is a 100 layer neural network ok; that
means, you are propagating back 100 different error signals to finally compute the derivative
of error e with respect to the parameters w in this particular layer ok.
This derivative is going to be very very small ok because you are multiplying this many numbers
and these numbers are generally small numbers ok. Sometimes they also explode that is the
other side, but for the most common problem is the vanishing gradient problem. So, what
happens if this number is small if this number is small what you recall your weight update
now. So, W t plus 1 is equal to W t minus this learning rate eta t times this gradient
of error with respect to W right. Now, this number is very small which means the change
in W will be very very small which means it will take a long long time to learn this particular
weight. What is the solution? The solution is something called unsupervised pre training.
So, what is unsupervised pre training? What you do is first you learn the initial pre
training weights of this particular layer by using an auto encoder network. So, you forget
about so let me just erase this. So, you forget about this neural network for the timing this
portion of the neural network which is a very deep neural network. You simply recreate,
you simply try to recreate the input from this particular layer ok. You simply try to
recreate the input from this particular layer and this you can think is something like you
are learning a representation you may not be able to fully recreate the input, but you
are trying to do something. The advantage of this is that this particular
network is now a very shallow network. So, you can update the parameter of this particular
network very very fast. So, then you have some initial parameter W 0 which are trained
or achieved using what is called this supervised fine tuning ok. So, this is unannotated data
ok you train. So, you train the first hidden layer, fix the parameters for the first hidden
layer then train the second hidden layer in this manner and then once you have trained
all the initial layer then you go ahead and do the back propagation on the entire neural
network. This is going to be very very fast. So, this is sometimes called unsupervised
pre-training of deep neural network and this achieve a much much faster training as compared
to the traditional back propagation type training ok. So, this completes the all the theory portion
of the neural network ok. Briefly, let us look at how this particular
thing can be implemented using a software called PyTorch. This will be taught in much
much more detail in the lab class ok, but just to give you an idea you need to write
this Python program which will basically import all the Torch libraries. So, this is importing
all the Torch libraries ok. Then you need to have all the hyper parameter. So, for example
let us say I am trying to now define a neural network which will process let us say MNIST
images and you know MNIST images are 28 cross 28 images ok. So, then you have basically
your input size or the number of neurons in the input layer is going to be 784. Hidden
size let us say we have taken 128 ok. Then we have taken number of classes which is also
going to be the size of the output layer ok. Then we have defined some other things like
how many epochs we want to train, what is the batch size, how many input data points
do you want to consider at a time. This basically this is related to the speed of the training
of the neural network ok. And then finally, learning rate which is the eta ok ok. And
now then you can define the neural network model like this. So, you see what we have
done is now we have defined these three layers basically the fully connected layer 1 which
is NN dot linear and its size is input size cross hidden size ok. Then we have a ReLU
activation function and then finally, we have another layer which is hidden size cross
number of classes ok. And then we have to also define the forward path ok, how the forward
computation goes. So, we take X ok and we readjust it a little bit and then we feed
X to the fully connected layer, then the output is fed to the ReLU layer and then the output
is fed to the other fully connected layer ok. So, the ReLU is actually not a layer here
it is an activation function ok. And this is basically the actual pi dot code for training
a multi-layer perception which can not training, but defining the model of the multi-layer
perception ok. Yeah and if you just run this code. So, so maybe I will provide this code
as a auxiliary as a extra file, you can just go through the whole code and then you can
see that you can basically train the neural network to achieve about 96 percent accuracy.
This is a very simple problem of course, for real world problems like this you need a more
complex neural network architecture which we will discuss in the next discussion ok.
And you can also compute a confusion matrix ok. So, with that I will stop and I will take
questions ok. We will take we can take questions straight away I think yeah ok.
Why are we using W transpose in which see here we are not using W transpose here we
are simply using W. So, in particular all the transposition. So, let me let me just
maybe show in a in a like just give me one minute I will just yeah. So, you see suppose
your W is let us say let us say 2 cross 3 ok. So, suppose you have a neural network
like this. So, you have x 1 or rather you have a layer like this x 1 x 3 and you have
output let us say h 1 and h 2 ok. Now, you have W i j is connecting. So, suppose you
have W i j which is connecting from x i to h j ok. So, how will it be? It will be so
your W matrix will be looking like this W 11, W 12, W 13 right sorry. So, then so if
it is connecting from x i to h j then you will have W 11, W 12, W 21, W 22 and W 31,
W 32 right why because your i is 3 your i varies from 1 to 3 and your j varies from 1 to 2
ok. Now, think about this i want to compute h j which is equal to summation over W i j
x i i is equal to 1 to 3 ok. If I multiply this is my W if I do a matrix multiplication
with x, x is going to be x 1, x 2 and x 3 ok. So, if I do a W times x what will happen?
It will not be the dimensions are not agreeing right. So, in that case we have to do a W
transpose x in that case you will see that W transpose x will basically be computing
this ok. So, your h 1 will be W like let me just erase this portion now ok.
So, so, so your W transpose is going to look like what? It is going to look like this now
W 11, W 12, W 21, W 22 and W 31, W 32. If I now multiply this with x i, x 1, x 2 and
x 3 ok. So, this times this is h 1, this times this is h 2 ok. So, the dimensions agree.
So, that is why you sometimes do W transpose. Is there any way to determine how many hidden
layers and you need in a layer should we have in a neural network ok. Yes, so the main strategy
that you should follow. So, you should have a educated guess that how many hidden features
or how many representations you need in the hidden layer ok.
Now, suppose you think that it should be at least five, you train your neural network
using just five units ok. You just define a neural network which has five as the number
of hidden units and you train it and you calculate the test set error ok. And now if you see
that or you do not even have to calculate the test set error, you first calculate the
training set error itself ok. And if you see your training set error is very high then
you have two choices either your number of hidden layers is not correct ok. In that case
you can increase the number of hidden layer or in each of the layers your number of units
is not correct ok. So, then you have to increase the number of units in a hidden layer ok.
You can have both options ok. So, you can try try and increasing the number of layers.
The positive of increasing the number of layers is that as I discussed you you will be creating
much more efficient neural networks. The deep neural networks are more efficient. So, you
need less number of hidden units ok. But the flip side of that is that your training time
will increase and if you go very very deep then you may have to use specialized training
techniques to train your neural networks. So, after you have gone let us say till four
or five hidden layer, you should probably start increasing the number of units in each
of these hidden layer ok. So, yeah so it is a trial and error process.
There is no there is no foolproof way of knowing exactly how many. You have to have a initial
guess that I will use initially you try two layer neural network with a certain number
of units in a given layer ok. And then if your training set error is very high you keep
increasing the number of layer and the number of units in each layer in order to achieve
a particular training error rate which is satisfactory to you.
How cyclic network be neural network? Earlier you mentioned cyclic graphs are not neural
network. Yes so that is what I mentioned that cyclic graphs are not neural network. So,
for example if you see yeah a graph I do not know if it is visible a graph like this ok
a graph like this is not a neural network. Whereas a directed acyclic graph directed
acyclic graph is a neural network. So, if you have a directed acyclic graph something
like this ok it is a neural network. So, you can for example have very very complicated
graph like this this is a valid neural network ok. But this one is not a neural network because
there is a directed acyclic cycle. So, the way to understand which one is a neural network.
So, here I mean so like I said there are I think there are two things that need to be
mentioned. There is a particular type of neural network called multilayer perceptron or something
also called sometimes also called feed forward neural network ok or sometimes also called
fully connected neural network ok all of them they mean the same thing. These are the types
of neural network that we discussed today for simplicity ok.
So, for example this one is not that type of neural network ok this is a general neural
network, but this is still a neural network because it is a network of neuron ok, but
this is not a valid neural network I hope this is clear right.
It understood the ZOR problem ok. So, let me go to the ZOR problem slide ok. So, this
is the ZOR problem ok yeah. So, in this slide you see what is the output the output. So,
first of all what is the input? Input is 0 comma 0 for this. So, each of these is data
point. So, this is a data point, this is a data point, this is a data point, this is
a data point ok. This is 1 comma 1, this is 1 comma 0 and this is 0 comma 1 ok. Output
the y for this one is going to be 0, for this one is going to be 0 that is why minus the
negative minus thing is written here, this one is going to be 1 ok and this one is going
to be 1. So, that is why plus is written here ok. So, that is the ZOR problem this is the
function you have to approximate using a neural network ok.
And this is the neural network that we designed we discussed this maybe we do not have the
time to go through that entire discussion now. So, you can see the all the calculation
is given here ok. So, you will see that you are using two hidden neurons H 1 and H 2.
H 1 neuron calculation for all the four points is given here ok. H 2 neuron calculation for
all the four points is given here. What you will what you can see if you go through this
is that H 1 is representing this particular boundary, H 2 is representing this particular
boundary ok. And then the final neuron here Y that calculation is given here ok that is
representing the final output where these two will come out to be 1 which is these two point
and this and this will come out to be 0 ok. So, this you can check. Why bias taking both
negative and positive value depending on what ok. So, bias you see like I told. So, what
is the purpose of bias? So, let me just maybe go back to the bias line yeah right. So, the
purpose of bias is to actually shift this activation function ok. So, suppose you have
F of W transpose X plus D. W transpose X by the way as you understand is summation over
W i X i i is equal to 1 to D ok. So, suppose this is 0 what will be the or let us say instead
of this being 0 let us say this is plus 1. What will be the output of the sigmoid function?
It will be plus 1 ok. Now, suppose you want that output of the sigmoid function to be
0 when this summation is plus 1, but plus 1 when this summation is plus 2 ok. So, what
you can do? You can set B to be minus 1. So, then when W. So, I am just writing here W
transpose X and W transpose X plus B and then output S these are the three things ok. So,
if W transpose X is plus 1 then W transpose X plus B is going to be 0. So, output is going
to be what? Output is going to be 0 ok or maybe like let us take this to be 1.1 something
like that. So, then this is minus 0.1. So, output is going to be 0. When it is plus 2
W transpose X is plus 2 then it is going to be plus 0.9. So, output is going to be 1.
You can see from this particular equation this particular graph. So, what you have done
effectively by setting B to be minus 1.1 what you have done is you have earlier the decision
boundary was at 0 W transpose X is equal to 0. Now, you have moved to W transpose X is
equal to 1 1 plus 1 1.1. So, the decision boundary is now at 1.1. So, that is the purpose
of the bias. In the given example we are selecting weight like 20 or 0.6 how are we deriving
those weights? Yes. So, like I said I am for the example I am coming up with the weight
right. In real life you do not have to come up with the weight ok, but here I am coming
up with the weight yeah. So, here I am coming up with the weight by simply inspecting what
should be the output. So, for example, for this yellow line my weights are 20 20 and
minus 10. Why am I saying this? Because for the yellow line you see when the input is
0 0 it should be 0 for all others it should be 1. So, sigma of minus 10 is 0 for all others
it is 1. So, instead of 20 we could have also taken something like 30 30, but then what
do I have to do? So, so so minus 10 will work here ok, but for this one if I take let us
say 30 30 ok. Now, you see I want this one to be 0 ok. So, if I take this to be minus
30 this to be minus 30 ok. Now, this summation for 1 1 data point will become what minus
60 ok. So, so now this one should be 0 ok. So, how much ok. So, plus 30 will work for
this one because it is going to be the resultant. So, plus 30 the resultant will be 30, but
now if I say 30 30 and plus 30 here let us say ok. This one will also become negative
you can see right because no this one will not become negative sorry if I take 40 here
let us say then this will not work because minus 40 into 1. So, consider the case where
if I take this to be minus 40 ok, then this data point will not be correctly satisfied.
So, you have to take the weight such that all of these outputs are satisfied ok. So,
that is how we are deriving the point. In general whenever we are deriving the weight
we are deriving it based on the output of that layer. So, here we know output of each
neuron beforehand this is going to be the output of each neuron that is why we can come
up with the weight. Weights are not unique there can be many weights which will lead
to this particular output ok. So, this is the end of the question answering
session. Thank you very much.